we are here to celebrate the completion
of the first survey
of the entire human genome
without a doubt this is the most
important most wondrous map
ever produced
by humankind
so
[Music]
in 2003 we definitely celebrated a
finished genome however the public was
unaware at the time that there were
hundreds of millions of bases that we
couldn't access at that point and so
because of that i would argue perhaps
some of the most biologically important
parts of our genome were largely ignored
for the past two decades
these were the centromeres people think
about chromosomes as being an x these
are the parts in the middle that hold
the x together they have a really
important biological function every time
your cell divides you have to
connect to these sites and pull your
chromosomes away and so if you have an
accident or some type of genomic
instability in these regions it can
cause anemoploidy cancers birth defects
things of that nature but we really
didn't know what sequences existed in
these regions before because they were
too hard to sequence and put together
also chromosome 13 14 15 21 and 22 were
completely off of our map and these
contained hundreds of genes which could
have important biological functions in
our understanding of human disease
and then finally there are large gaps
even in the arms of our chromosomes that
contain gene family expansions and
things that we call segmental
duplications that have been shown to be
very important for understanding of
clinical genetics and genomics and even
population and evolutionary genetics
when we had the fully sequenced and
complete genome it was thrilling
something i had been looking forward to
my entire career so in that way it was
very fulfilling
i think it's kind of like any explorer
when you see new land or new maps for
the first time it's more than just
seeing it there's kind of a promise
there of new discoveries that will be
made in that landscape
with the completion of this one genome
it's easy to think that we've reached
the end um that this is really a place
for us all to sign our names and to you
know throw the final party and say it's
done but the truth of the matter is that
this is just one more individual who
happens to be of european descent and
where we'd like to go is to have a whole
panel of complete reference assemblies
from a collection of humanity really
representing highly diverse individuals
and then understanding all of the
variation that makes
us human and that will really bring into
light a lot of these biological and
clinical and evolutionary questions that
come along with understanding the
complete and finished genome
[Music]
you